My guest tonight is the author
of the New York Times Best Selling,
Rad Women Series.
Her latest book
is called 'Rad American History A-Z'.
She's also a fierce advocate
for social justice,
who's shedding light on
racism, feminism, politics,
and the responsibilities of white people
in the world today, as if-
Wow, that, think that covers everything.
I don't think we need
to do an interview now.
Please welcome,
Kate Schatz.
Hi, Kate.
Hi, hi Conan.
How are you?
Thank you for being here
and let me explain our,
our trajectory,
to anyone who may not know
Yes.
Right after the killing of George Floyd,
we had two weeks of discussions
on my show.
Trying to just open it up,
talk to a lot of different people.
One of the first people I talked to
was W. Kamau Bell, who's
a friend of mine over the years,
a guy I know
and trust, and I thought,
"Let's have this conversation."
And one of the first things
he did in his interview, he said,
"Conan, I'm going to
assign you-"
What was the word he used?
A whiteness counselor.
I think so,
I think he said that I
was gonna be in charge
of your whiteness.
In charge of my whiteness,
and first of all,
I thought,
"I pity whoever's in
charge of my whiteness
because,
that is a lot of whiteness
to be in charge of."
So much,
blinding.
Yeah, and then I thought,
I got confused 'cause I thought
"Well wait, is this person
you're assigning me to.
If she's there to help me be more white,
it's not necessary."
Apparently that's,
that's not what it was all about,
and we have
started up a bit of a dialogue, you and I,
and I've been looking through your books
and I'm very impressed.
But tell me, when
when our mutual friend said,
"Whiteness counselor-
or you're in charge of my whiteness."
How did you interpret that?
(laughing)
And a,
so, I interpreted that as,
you know,
it was kind of an offshoot
of a conversation,
that Kamau and I have had,
you know, earlier that week.
So,
in the wake of the murder
of George Floyd and the
uprising around racial justice,
that we saw and experienced,
and are still experiencing.
Kamau texted me and said,
basically he was like,
"Hey, all these rich,
powerful, white people
with tons of privilege keep asking me
what do I do."
And he was like,
"I don't know what to tell them.
Can I send them to you?
Is there like a website y'all have,
like for white people?
Like, what do I do with them?"
And I wrote him back and I was like,
"Yes, send them my way.
Kamau, of course. Like,
you don't need to deal
with that right now."
I did not expect the first person
for him to send my way to be you.
[Conan] Yes, it happened immediately
and it's the worst news you ever got.
No!
(laughing)
You know,
it was great and,
you know, what I really saw it of
was an opportunity to
do what I think I've always tried to do,
which is, you know,
leverage my platform and my privilege
to make some kind of impact,
whether it's through my books or through
teaching, which I did for many years.
Or through just having conversations so,
I thought "Well,
I've got a lot of new followers
on Twitter and on Instagram, and
I really believe that in
this particular moment,
white people have a lot of questions."
And they deserve to be able to ask them.
[Conan] Yeah. - They're
all great questions.
No, no.
But there's a lot of confusion,
and there was and is still a lot of,
"What do I do? What's the
most effective thing to do?
What's happening?"
Those questions don't need
to be directed necessarily to
your black friends, and colleagues,
and neighbors.
So, I was like "Well,
I'll just get on Instagram
and ask people to send me their questions
and we'll just start talking."
And I got
hundreds of questions, I still do,
and I've been doing my best
to answer them, honestly.
So many people,
and I'm gonna include myself,
who feel
like "Oh my god, I don't
wanna make a mistake."
[Kate] Yeah.
I wanna be an ally,
I want to move the peace forward,
I want to be the solution
and not part of the problem,
but I'm terrified of making a mistake.
And that leads to,
I think a paralysis
that is not helping.
Can you speak to that a little bit?
Yeah, you know
I like kind of using the term, you know,
co-conspirators or accomplices,
rather than allies. You know?
But those folks
are the people who've made mistakes,
and who've heard the feedback,
learned and kept going. Right?
That paralysis is,
it's no,
it's really, really, I think actually
really selfish.
And incredibly unhelpful. You will-
So, the question isn't "What do I do if
I say the wrong thing?" It's
"When I do the, or say the wrong thing,
what's the best way for me
to respond in that moment?"
You know, we're all gonna mess up
and it's not just around race.
Men are gonna say the
wrong thing to women,
we're gonna Misgender people.
We're all, you know,
we are all gonna do
and say the wrong thing
and cause someone harm,
so often in a way that
we're absolutely not
meaning to, and that's,
so often what people say is
"That wasn't my intention."
"I didn't mean that, that
wasn't my intention."
But if something that you
do or say harms someone,
and they let you know that,
what you need to be able to do is
listen to them and hear them,
and understand you can
do better the next time.
You know, and if we
just let that paralysis,
you know takeover and we
just don't say anything,
that's part of the large
systemic problem that we have.
The-
Obviously a lot of people talking about
the book 'White Fragility',
which I believe was written
about a year or two ago,
but you know,
immediately became this,
very sought after book.
After the killing of George Floyd,
and people talking about,
discussing what's in there,
what I found was really interesting was,
in that book,
there's addressing this idea that
white people have so much
fear and sensitivity about race,
that we're afraid to make a mistake,
and then you think about it.
You think, "Well, a faux pas
is a small price to pay for
trying to engage. Meaning,
if the price that I'm gonna have to pay
to educate myself and to
grow and evolve, is to be embarrassed
a bunch of times.
That is less than the size of an atom,
compared to the Himalayan
mountains, which are
hundreds of years of
racial discrimination,
so get over it.
I think- I encourage people to think,
"Well, what's the worst
thing that can happen?"
Right? - [Conan] Right.
If you put on a Black
Lives Matter tee shirt,
or you put a sign on your window, or you
take the step to bring
something up to a family member,
and that's like, you know,
might be uncomfortable or awkward,
or even really contentious.
What's the worst thing that can happen
and what are you willing to risk
for something that you believe?
You know, and I think that-
What I wanna encourage people to do
is to get cleaner on your beliefs.
If you believe that we have a
history of systemic
racism in this country,
if you believe
that black and brown people
are disproportionally
mistreated by police.
You believe these things,
and you believe that black lives matter,
then, you know,
what are you willing to
risk to talk about that
and to share that message
with people in your community?
In some ways, very simple and yet clearly,
we talk about,
there's the paralysis and fear
that we see in this country
about people were to make a mistake.
And then the flip side,
what I wanna ask you about,
is defensiveness.
Oh, yeah.
It's a very simple thing to
go "I don't know, maybe I did.
Maybe I did make a mistake.
Maybe I was biased.
Maybe, maybe-
How could I not be biased?"
Let's talk about it,
is such a simple thing to do but,
people put up this defensive wall.
And it's that defensiveness
that I think is
the hardest thing to get over.
It is, and you know, to-
What I like to,
you know I kind of like to
turn it around and say like,
"Well, what exactly are you defending?"
You know? When you get that upset
because we've had this
conversation and it's,
that's the thing, it's not just about
getting accused of doing something
that is seen as racist. You know?
People will be furious
that you and I are actually
having this conversation.
You know, so for those people it's like,
"What are you so upset about?
How is this harming you?
What exactly are you defending?
Are you just defending white supremacy?
Are you defending, you know,
that position?"
Yeah, it's the-
The defensiveness is huge, and I
you know, I really appreciate,
you know, you-
I appreciate you having me
on, and I appreciate you
being willing to have this conversation
after the fact, right?
Because, I think that
in all these conversations
that we have about
what white people can be doing and
be better and all this
stuff. I think accountability
and follow up is a huge part of it.
Right? So, we can have this conversations
in the weeks after these
horrific things happen.
But then we, kind of go
back to normal. Right?
Yeah, I was gonna show, like,
I don't have it as a,
but I was gonna like
hold up my phone and say,
"We are very much
a society
that's like "What are
we talking about now?"
So, right now it's
Trump's getting impeached.
And that's all anybody
wants to talk about,
and then we move on.
And then it's COVID,
And then George Floyd is killed and,
everybody says "This is now
what we're gonna talk about."
And you think "This is fantastic."
And, it's not that people
are consciously saying,
dismissing it as an issue.
But then COVID resurges and we move on.
And then, that is,
I think the issue is
so much good
dialogue,
so much good dialogue
and so much raw emotion was vented
in the last two months,
that you think,
"Let's-"
Sort of a path has been opened.
I don't think we've ever seen sustained
anger and concern like
that in my life time.
I'm 28.
Yeah, I-
You're a lot younger than me so.
Yeah yeah,
it's just sun damage."
(laughing)
But, we haven't seen this
and yeah, this is a,
an opportunity to
keep the path open, and keep exploring.
So, you're right, I mean,
I do think it's essential to not say
"Well, check."
[Kate] Mhm.
We did racism.
[Kate] Yep, right.
We pulled down a bunch of statues and,
I think we're good. Let's move on.
Because-
Yeah, 'cause we haven't
moved on, you know the
Breonna Taylor's killers
are still walking free.
And there's still people in Louisville
who've been protesting every single day,
for months. Getting arrested and
not relucting and so,
you know I think
sometimes what happens too
is that for,
especially with, you know, white people.
If it's not immediately in your feed
and in your immediate-
in front of your face, in your feed,
then you think "Oh, it's not-
It doesn't exist anymore." So, I think
you know, the level of at which we saw,
a ton of protests happening,
all over, all the time, constantly.
That's still happening in a lot of places,
it just might not be
showing up in your feed so,
you know, be sure to be
diversifying your feed
and paying attention to it
'cause it's all still happening.
But I think you're right,
that there is a path that's open and,
this is a time for people
to really be thinking critically about
how do you stay on that path.
Now, that doesn't mean
that everything you do now,
has to be completely, you know,
all about racial justice
unless that's the work
that you really wanna be doing.
I've been watching
everybody you've had on,
and you've had great
people on, that I love.
And you've had some
incredible conversations
with your black guest that you've had on.
Well, what happens when
Will Ferrell comes on?
I love Will.
You know, what does it look like when
in addition to his new movie,
you also say "Hey, like-
How are you feeling about, you know,
the changes in society. What-
Right.
How did the killing of
George Floyd affect you?
You know, Will or Rob Lowe, or
whatever person's on.
And that's where there's like a real-
That's unexpected, and
I think that's where
the needle starts to get moved.
You know, and it's-
goes back to that idea about
discomfort, like that's-
White people do not expect to be asked
about race,
because we don't see ourselves as
part of race. We often see
racism as something that happens
to other people,
who do not look like us and,
we didn't do it. Right?
But we are actually
totally complicit and
white supremacy
impacts us all negatively. So.
No-
I think that's a really good point.
I think it's-
What's interesting about it is
the concept that,
when you're talking to people,
and this is something,
honestly don't know the answer.
But where I'm talking to
people in entertainment
about their project, is then figuring out
a way to do it,
which doesn't look like
a "Gotcha,"
doesn't look like I've,
you know.
And also asking them,
they may have very visceral,
strong feelings about it
and they may not be
prepared to talk about that.
So, there needs to be a way to figure out,
how can I-
How can that be part of the conversation,
on going.
Without it looking like I'm
trying to make people uncomfortable.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah, but you always are
kinda making people
uncomfortable. You know?
That's just my appearance.
That's true.
(laughing)
I can't do anything about that.
I know, I can't believe I'm
having to look at this
for so long. (laughing)
The thin lips and the eyes,
and yeah.
No, but I agree that,
that there needs to be
many different ways.
Like, one of the approaches that
I've wanted to take is,
how can I-
Not even so much as a
person with whatever
kind of platform I have.
I'm always weary of my platform,
because I think my,
and I think I should
be weary of my platform
'cause I, I'm not even
comfortable with the word,
I feel like I'm someone who
has some ability of
being silly and that is,
brought me into people's homes
for a long period of time.
And so I'm weary of leaning against it,
like the most important
thing to me has been,
how do I personally-
how do I evolve?
How do I change the culture that's,
my ecosystem around me,
how can I improve it?
How can I make changes that,
and sort of lead by example.
Does that make sense?
Makes perfect sense.
You know, taking inventory
of who's working for you, you know.
By the way, everybody you work with
that I've interacted with so far,
has been the nicest people ever. So,
good job. Love them all.
I've tried to fire them,
but they have legal protections
All right. - which
infuriates me, you know.
Damn labor movement.
What I really want-
What I really want is
a staff of shit-heads,
but I legally don't know how to,
how to pull it off. I
don't know how to do it.
I'm sure you could find a lawyer
who could help you figure that one out.
No, I think that, you know like,
whether it's looking around at
who you are appointing,
who are you working
with, who are you hiring,
what is your writing room look like.
You know, who you are bringing in
and what is it like to be
intentional about that.
You know, but um,
but I wouldn't just say that the idea of
how do you bring up those conversations
in ways that don't feel like a "Gotcha."
You know, I again, I think
black entertainers have been,
that's what they do.
I watched the wonderful Nicole Byer
when you had her on, she's hilarious.
And she talked both about the pain
and the challenge of this moment,
and she also talked about
her amazing new book.
You know.
What's uh,
great is,
when I love-
So many people are.
We have a writer on our
staff, Laurie Kilmartin,
who's very good
at talking about-
She just lost her mother to COVID,
and she was able to
take that pain, and um,
and braid it,
intertwine it with humor
in this way that was like a razor's edge.
And I think
Chris read,
from Saturday Night Live was on,
and he was, you know,
he can be so funny where he's
walking the razor's edge of,
he can bring up being afraid of
hearing someone be
racist when he's playing
a video game, and they
don't know who he is
and maybe someone's gonna, you know,
shout out the n-word.
And not know that he's there.
But he was very funny
talking about that in a way that-
It's such a powerful weapon
to be funny
and bring up
the biggest nuclear bomb issue
in American history for the last
250 years,
and somehow combine the two.
Those, I mean um,
it's so many entertainers
are so good at doing that.
And I think that's a very
powerful tool as well.
And I think that's, you know,
it's what I always loved about Kamau,
and his work is how he does.
And you know yeah, comedy's a
incredible powerful tool and,
you can, you know, you can do so much,
you can go places and have conversations
that people ordinarily
will be too afraid to go to.
Conan, I wanted to ask you a question.
Yeah. I'd love to hear
what you've been learning, you know,
you wrote me a wonderful
email and really laid out
a lot of things you've
been thinking about so,
I'd love for you to tell the class
about some of the work
you've been doing. (laughing)
Well, I got stoned.
I didn't write the paper.
(laughing)
Then I wrote something
but my dog ate it, and uh.
Yeah, no um.
What, I mean,
we talked a little bit about it
but one of the things is-
I love to read so the first thing
that I did, and I didn't
want it to feel like
I'm doing a good job
and doing my assignment.
I really wanted it to feel like,
I want to do this for me, you know?
I wanna, so um,
one of the first things I
read and I was ashamed that
I hadn't read it before
because it's a book
that has been around my whole life,
is the 'Autobiography of Malcolm X'.
And um,
it is one of the most heroing stories,
personal stories, that
you're ever gonna read.
It's, it-
and it takes place in Roxbury,
which is right near where I grew up.
And it, obviously,
Malcolm X is growing up
in the 1940's, and 50's in Roxbury,
and then moving to Harlem.
But that transformation
is absolutely incredible,
and you can't read that book
and not see that this person,
I think his father dies violently,
at the hands of racists.
And his whole life is
all about the color of his skin,
and it completely,
and he's obviously incredibly intelligent,
and incredibly talented,
and incredibly good-looking
and charismatic.
And its-
You see how his entire life
is changed by
institutional racism,
and you completely
understand his point of view
by the time you get to 1960, 61
and he's 62 and he's saying,
"Look, I'm-
I respect Dr. Martin Luther King, and
peaceful protest and everything."
But you understand how he got to
any means necessary.
You completely understand it.
So,
there's things as simple as uh,
reading a book.
There's also tons of
conversations you can be having.
And there are ways that
you can think about,
"How can I take my little world and
make changes in it, that will,
for me and the people around me,
advance this movement a little bit."
And so, the question is-
And it's, we've had a lot
of talks about it with
my producer and with people on the show.
Just talking about, you know,
what can we do. What can we
do in the makeup of our show?
What can we do in uh-
and talking, not just with the show,
but my wife and my kids.
What can we be doing day-in and day-out?
And one of the nice things is,
if my kids are any example.
One is 16, my daughter's 16,
and my son's 14.
They're absolutely um,
it's a generation and uh,
and their friends as well.
They're very, very interested
in making this world better,
and racially fair than it has been.
They're very- I mean it's
not the top of their list,
and so, that's inspiring.
That's helpful.
Now, I did send your family
shirts that match the one I'm wearing.
Mhm, yep.
Did the kids get the Black
Lives Matter care package?
Yes, they did. And I got your
Black Lives Matter shirt as well.
There you go, Conan.
Um, and uh
you know, I-
And this leads me to my next question,
which is-
I don't have a confusion about this,
I wanna make that clear,
but there has been a common refrain
among certain people in this country.
I think I know where
you're going with this one.
That say, "Black lives matter, well,
all lives matter." And,
I have a point of view about that,
very strong point of view about that,
but why don't you tell us
what you see the distinction being.
Yeah, that's just not something
that I debate, you know?
Right.
That's just not a debate. And you know,
I think that the way that I-
Actually, I do touch on that
here in this book I wrote.
Oh look, you have your own
book with you, right there.
It's a super coincidence,
I didn't even realize it was right here.
(laughing)
That is so lucky, I'm so relieved.
And actually, in this book,
again which is an a-z book of
radical moments and movements
from American history,
and many of which we don't
learn about in schools.
B is for black lives matter.
And it's about the three women
who founded the movement.
And I actually address
that, so I'm just gonna read
my paragraph about that.
All right.
Well I say:
Some non-black people feel
threatened or left out
by the phrase "black lives matter".
"What about us?" they've argued,
"Why single out black lives?
Don't all lives matter?"
The answer is yes,
of course, every human life matters,
but until all humans are
actually treated equally in this country,
it is justified and
vital to bring attention
to certain groups who have been routinely,
statistically, and historically harmed.
That is my succinct,
kind of succinct, explanation.
In other words-
What no, it's very good I just was setting
if, a sense memory.
No one's read to me,
since I was about five,
and it was fantastic and-
Your eyes glazed over, you started to nap.
No, no, no, no, much-
No they didn't glaze over but,
much better content than the stuff
they were reading me when I was five.
Yeah, we could do this.
I could zoom with you at night
and read all these stories.
(laughing)
What if my wife.
My wife's gonna walk in
and go who's that woman
that you're talking to,
at three o' clock in the morning?
And I'll be like, "No, no, no,
we're talking about race," and she'll say
"Yeah, okay. I want a divorce."
Well, you know, its-
will say, one thing I found
in writing these books, because the books
that I write with my
collaborator, Miriam Klein Stahl,
they're aimed at young readers.
But, I do a lot of school visits,
well in the,
before times I would go
in the classrooms a lot.
And I always loved to
read to young people, but
I love reading to high school students
and college students,
and I'll read to adults.
We all really like to be read to. So, um,
so ya, that's my answer. Black lives-
I had the same feeling which is,
I mean immediately, which is
the reason-
The statement "black lives
matter" comes out of this
incredibly,
incredible undeniable history of neglect.
That's why the statement needs to be made.
In the first-
So, then to say,
"Well, wait a minute.
No, all lives matter,"
is to deny that we have an issue,
we have a specific racial
issue in this country.
Yeah, and at this point also,
you know, at this point
in the conversation,
in the movement, in our country.
At this point to say "All lives matter,"
that is an expressly
violent and racist statement
at this point. We're beyond context.
In fact, here where I live,
I live in Alamy to California,
right next to Oakland.
Several black families in town,
recently woke up to find
their cars vandalized.
Their tires had been slashed,
they've been keyed, and all lives mater,
"ALM" had been spray
painted all over the car.
This is in the,
the liberal Bay Area,
so that's, it's-
We're beyond the conversation of debating
whether black- the phrases.
[Conan} Yeah.
And, you know, black lives matter,
and again, I talk about it in the book.
That phrase began with
conversations amongst
three black women who were friends,
who were feeling
unbelievable rage and sorrow,
when George Zimmerman was acquitted
of the murder of Trayvon Martin.
And they literally just typed on Facebook,
"I feel like black lives don't matter,"
and then they turned that in and said,
"You know what? Black lives do matter.
Black lives matter," and they started that
as a hashtag, initially to share love
and to uplift their community.
And then as it caught on, they were like
"Wow, this may be, is
a movement," and then
they built it into a global movement, and
those women are Alicia Garza, Opal Tometi,
and Patrisse Cullors.
And they have been propelling this,
and you know, it's a,
it's an important phrase,
we put it on the cover of the book too.
And I do-
One of things when I
first started doing these
Instagram lives, after I
received my promotion to
being in charge of your whiteness.
[Conan] Trust me, it's a demotion.
Well, I have-
I wasn't working a lot
because of quarantine,
so I had some time.
Take the jobs that come your way.
Basically.
So, but,
one of the first things I
talked to people about was,
you know, if you're wondering
what to do right now
as you're grappling with "What can I do?
What do I read? Which book?"
Get a piece of paper, write
"black lives matter" on it,
and tape it up on your window. You know?
And if you can't take that step,
if you're a white person and
you're not ready to do that,
to make your support visible,
then there's a lot more kind of deep work
that you have to do,
and that could maybe show
you what you need to do,
but if you could do that.
It actually,
it does have an impact,
I've been hearing a lot of
really powerful stories of,
of how that show of solidarity and support
has had so much meaning to so many people.
Um, the last thing I wanted to bring up
was uh, something that
all of us are grappling with right now.
Talking to someone,
who doesn't agree with you wanting to
change their perception,
maybe convince them,
and it feels like we're
in a place in our country,
where someone's with you or they're not.
Someone's in your group
or they're in the other group, and
I'm just saying this as a,
I'm trying to address everybody with this.
If you're a rabid Trump supporter,
or if you think he's the anti-Christ.
How can we get to a place where we can
talk about these things?
You can't shout someone
down and yell at them
and intimidate them into agreeing with you
about some of these issues.
So, what do you do?
Yeah, it's the,
it's the age-old question. Um,
I think you make,
you make strategic smart choices
that conserve your energy,
and protect your humanity.
And also our
good uses of your energy. Right?
And so, I think that sometimes,
I will say I've never
ever, ever seen an argument
be one, in a Facebook thread.
[Conan] No, have you ever seen it happen?
No. I've never seen online anyone go,
"You know what? I've
been thinking about it,
and you're right. UFO's don't exist."
(laughing)
So, I think there can be,
when you really believe something
and you're seeing stuff online.
It's very tempting to get into it.
I, at this point in my world,
I don't do that.
Your hair looks great by
the way. It's incredible.
You know, I think that should be the most
important thing everyone takes away
from this conversation.
It is, it is.
Conan's hair, and then
race relations in America.
I have my priorities straight.
Yeah, you know maybe you could like,
we could like spray paint
"black lives matter"
onto your hair, then it could just be
always there. Right?
Okay. All right, we could do that.
Sort of an orange.
Sometimes I found,
for people who have family members,
especially maybe older
generation family members
who they're, they want to be able to
connect with over this but it's hard.
Sometimes connecting through history,
through like historical events
can be a kind of way in,
to get to those conversations and,
I also think that we have
to accept that we're just
not gonna change everybody's mind.
And I don't think, I don't,
there's people who disagree with me,
I do not think that you,
that we are under an,
that we are obligated to get into
long drawn-out conversations
with people who don't
respect the basic humanity
of the people that we love. You know?
And that said, I think that
if you do see someone online
who, you know,
you wanna engage with them
or it's a family member.
Asking people if they're willing to
talk to you offline.
You know, "Hey,
I have a different opinion
and I'd be really
interested in sharing about
like what I believe. Would you ever be
willing to talk to me,
you know. Privately.
Or on the phone." You know?
And if you can come.
I mean I think that for
people who are interested
in having those conversations,
learning the basics of
non-violent communication
is incredibly helpful,
because I agree with you.
You're not gonna shout, people-
It can go from zero to like ten million,
so quickly, because people get so upset .
[Conan] Especially right now.
I mean,
it's always been that way, but right now
it feels definitely like a powder keg and,
we're seeing everyday.
We talked about this before,
on social media,
people have even taking wearing masks,
face masks, as a basic protection.
They've somehow made that
an issue that they've tied to,
you know, race or,
income, wealth.
They've tied it to all this other stuff-
freedom, government versus no-government.
And it's like no, no,
just put on a (beep)
mask. It's really simple.
Just put on a (beep) mask. But, no.
That's,
we've-
If people are losing it over
wearing a piece of paper
over their mouths for the ten minutes
that they're at a Costco.
We see what's gonna happen
when you're implying
that there,
part of a racist system that needs to be,
that needs to be fixed.
They're gonna really lose it.
That's where you choose
your battles. Right?
That's where you choose, "Is this
gonna be worth the energy
that it's gonna take me
and could I use my energy elsewhere?
I'll tell you that, you
know, a lot of people
that I talked to who have struggled with
really racist family members.
The aunt and uncle, grandma, grandpa,
the parents, they made me far gone.
But those nieces and nephews,
those little cousins,
you know.
[Conan] Right.
Send them my books.
You know? Have those conversations,
like you said about your kids.
Like they're a different generation so,
sometimes I think maybe if it's,
if you're the aunt,
connecting with that niece or nephew.
In a way that doesn't like, you know,
interfere with the parents.
Don't talk to any of my relatives,
that's how I take care of it.
It's all-
my manager talks to everyone for me.
You know-
He tells me they're lovely people.
(laughing)
The other thing I'd say is,
sometimes I think about
talking to people who don't get it,
or who you disagree with,
you know, it's almost like talking to my
almost-seven year old son.
Where I have to remind myself
that we're gonna have a
lot of conversations where
what I say in the moment, may not seem to
change anything with him.
But it's gonna sink in overtime.
[Conan] Right. And, I think that it's
still worth
doing your best to share resources,
recommend books, recommend documentaries.
Maybe the back-and-forth on Facebook
isn't gonna change anything.
But like, maybe you can get that aunt to
listen to the 16.19 podcast. You know?
Or to watch 'When They See Us',
or to watch 'Thirteenth'. You know?
Maybe just putting those
resources out there,
maybe that can work
with someone over time.
And they might not change their mind
in the moment that your
in the conversation,
but some stuff could sink in.
That's how I feel about parenting
basically at all times.
Well I,
appreciate this conversation a lot.
Me too, Conan.
I like to be an optimist and I
like to know that good
people are out there
trying to do good work and so,
I'm-
Wait, I have one more question.
I know we're supposed to-
I am curious to know,
like what is one thing that
you learned from my book
that you were like fascinated to learn
as a history buff, that
you didn't know before?
Well, I'm gonna say Maya Lin.
What I didn't know was that
Maya Lin was in college,
when she designed the Vietnam memorial,
and that,
she got that much opposition to it
and that she fought back.
What college student, who is told
"Yes, we're gonna build your monument.
We just need you to make
a few changes." Says,
"I don't think so. It's
good the way it is."
And then it turned out to be a
such a stunning success.
That's one of the coolest,
I mean, the book's,
the book's filled with
very amazing stories.
That was the one that stuck with me
'cause I was so shocked,
that someone that young
just had the guts and temerity
and vision, and then saw
it all the way through.
And then it turned into a massive success
in her lifetime,
immediate-
Not like Van,
not like Van Gogh like where,
okay, maybe he's a ghost somewhere
and he's appreciating
and his stuff is making
a lot of money.
He's a one-eared ghost, but uh,
yeah, I really loved that.
Excellent, Van Ghost.
Van Ghost, exactly.
All right, I'll do the comedy here.
(laughing) Listen, back off.
All right, thank you very much, and
as I said Kate's book is called
'Rad American History A-Z',
it's available now.
And Kate Schatz, thank you very much
for doing this.
Thank you, Conan. You're doing a good job,
I'm very proud of you.